gained like four pounds of muscle dude
really exactly I'm actually a little too
thick for my jeans lately I'm all ass
and tits told ya I feel it and I'll have
you know I was I walked outside and this
car full of women went holy did you
report him yeah I was like I'm not a
piece of meat here he's reported not a
piece of meat yeah I did don't you join
other businesses guys even though you're
gonna make money which way did that make
stitches oh [ __ ] bacon depends I think
the New York one was like a thousand
dollars What's in LA there's money you
know it's tempting tempting
they just drive around snitching on
people you got bells [ __ ] I remember
when my dad bought that Neil politan ice
cream and it was it was strawberry
chocolate and vanilla and I hated the
chocolate and I loved the strawberry I
remember I ate all the strawberry and I
was chill on the couch like you know he
work 9:00 to 4:00 kiss ass off came home
probably was feigning some strawberry
ice cream goes in there and he goes
bread cuz I was always the ice cream kid
he was Brandon and I'm like I'm laying
on the couch you know like this watching
pretty [ __ ] I don't know Animaniacs
or some [ __ ] and he goes you ate all the
ice cream I go I'll eat the strawberry
goes god you're a fat pig good luck not
like mean was like God you fat pig but
it sounds worse I'm saying he was just
saying I God you fat pig like yeah
goddamn doing then walked off yeah oh
dude really
Oh tattooed on the heart fat pig yeah
certainly gotta be careful certainly
yeah especially because yeah I was tough
fat pig has kind of rough alright I was
like hmm I would never say it to my kid
my sister is that when we were in that
we were in Mykonos and this Italian girl
or she made him in French she said my
sister we were all dancing him and we
kind of got on a bum pompous confidence
pompous cough with this other group of
Italian kids and the woman called my
sister a pig nothing worse my sister
who's [ __ ] Teflon my sister goes
what'd she call me and
my buddy Regulus she called you a page
this is Tom my sister goes well tell her
that this pig is gonna punch her right
in the face that just American South
yeah and they were you everything that
never lies Jesus what I think I tell her
her brother a punch the guy's the pig's
brother will punch them in the faith as
pigs will [ __ ] you guys that say you
know we're pigs and we'll [ __ ] it he's
American pigs you bring it but bring him
a [ __ ] it weirdo certain stuff man it
just [ __ ] with you I for me the part
of me I've never saw the this summer we
got molested a tad now at the tattoo on
my heart was there was this kid Ronnie
who was muscular I always knew he in a
t-shirt
he had a chest and stomach muscles just
the kid and I remember my girlfriend and
her sisters talking about how sexy sexy
he was in a t-shirt and how it ripples
and I was there and I was like you don't
have that dude and my girlfriend I was
like first of all I was like girls find
muscles sexy didn't know that I didn't I
was too young I was 14 or 13 really well
didn't autonomy well I remember I didn't
have muscles so girls like me yeah but
they're like me for something else yeah
so I was like I was like oh no I I don't
have I don't rip all under a t-shirt
though I'm skinny it's not that was the
worst I never forgot it though those
certain things that like [ __ ] burn
into your [ __ ] but I want to be part
of this nope I mean BM mana right
remember you carry the flag and do this
hey guys know what at the finish line
you wave the flag like this MA and then
you get water for the big boys really
I've only boy why go and fetch water
yeah you're the water boy I'm the water
boy I think boy water but I do it in a
pail no I got your water boys don't make
me cook up highs and stuff who cook hula
don't make me cook pies in an apron who
pies yeah
don't make me be a bad little handle
bars in granola bars baby boys your pies
are ready hope you don't mind my apron
whoops forgot to wear anything
underneath my little buddy what he is
sticking out thick boys boys dumping you
know I would never you guys better not
hold me down I'll be so mad blur see
your apple pie
I hope you like it if you don't like it
don't punish me for her it's already put
enough cinnamon on the Apple that what
the [ __ ] oh Jesus Christ
what the [ __ ] it's a Marc Maron podcast
that one was hey man Jesus Christ thank
God you got me out of my game I know
they torn teen [ __ ] boys to run some no
no no I just got I got a little weight
and a bike down you leave some leave
some tracks huh I'm better should I
polish your guys spike oh my little
rattlesnake or what oh you know we did a
rat snake fire you guys better not I
don't have use Runkle we spank their
butt oh [ __ ] Daisy who everybody's in
Spanish good news everybody shaved down
again covered in mineral oil so I'm
gonna be real slippery who wants pie
dude we're not serving pie come on but
pie how about some energy jell-o
ener divide the jello here it comes
provide the job of employee yeah that's
old it's all smells like dust
I loved your your post my sister my
sister sent me your post of just making
fun of celebrities about the sacrifice
well yeah because there's a lot of
people that are out now being like it's
time to just heal heal your body heal
your mind yeah
take a breath somebody I was literally -
Mikey a nurse Italy and she's like take
a breath and she goes just be just be
I'm like you know we could just be
people don't have food they you don't
felipito Donnie for one living with
three people have me while they're in
their mansion just breathe
trust eating this meal right sick
kitchen with his two miniature ponies
yeah have you seen this at Bodhi
they're both and he goes guys stay at
home both must stay at home yeah and be
safe I'm just eating my you know eat
good food
come on dude it's so yeah it's amazing
watch this it's pretty cool estupido
those rain is the greatest it's the
greatest is it I was on Instagram
account one thing is that you stay at
home I bet he hasn't touched those
things in years they hang out with him
all the time he shot them in the head
yes singing a sword is 65 unitl out of
the house and in my california so you
stay home and behave here yeah you got a
lot of this visit terminator sure I
don't care he's great come on do it you
better hit man oh yeah a lot of these
people are like who's that Tim I'm they
on that far in their console Elgort did
a naked selfies to somebody online just
put my head on him I just posted it this
is again out celebrities are helping
it's like hey I'm naked in the shower
hey sorry you're eating your grandma
right but I'm naked in a shower and I
won't be enjoyed years ago had an old
black guy go out this to me I've never
forgot it I was old like I said he said
enjoying freedom now and I said what do
you mean he goes no he said enjoy your
privacy now I said what do you mean he
goes you see that camera there was a
camera it was a traffic camera and he
goes in ten years
everywhere you go you will be on camera
and I went okay right I do love your
spirit Sofia
he was so prescient that he saw the fact
that no matter where we go we will
always be able that's what your
neighbors and preachers usually bring
here's what's read the reality was
coming Ted Kaczynski by the way there's
gonna be fully autonomous cities where
people gonna buy into a city it's gonna
be sterilized
all your health information all of your
personal information your credit
information social media it's all gonna
be logged in you're gonna get a face
will be recognized yeah facial
recognition you're nothing you'll be no
more physical marketplaces you will not
go to a store everything will be
delivered to you everything you do will
be tracked there will be no automobile
ownership you're gonna get in a fleet of
self-driving cars everything is going to
be engineered the simulation it's gonna
be it's gonna be wild dude we're not
gonna see a lot of it but the beginning
of it
a friend of mine works at Deutsche Bank
because we're already looking at the
financial infrastructure black works
well Leo Deutsche Bank he goes fully
autonomous term cities meaning that you
would buy into the city like you
wouldn't buy a home in Santa Monica you
would buy cinema you do it into a into a
it's like a condo into a craft into a
kind of thing but again its approval
will require all of the things Health
social media they're looking to be like
we don't want a lunatic who's who's
going crazy in social media here
how healthy are you like because you're
gonna be using all of the you're gonna
be using all the public all your data
will be available I think how little be
while dude it's gonna be a wild world
we're gonna be yeah well the question
will be then then they'll sell services
to make your data private then there'll
be privacy movements there'll be times
where it's like we do things the
old-fashioned way we're old school
whatever it is but I do think you're
right I think I mean it's too convenient
to do that I'm a futurist and I study
future systems why part of what I do
hold on
part of what I do is study the
integration of Technology at a future
point where technology will integrate
with and then future systems will arrive
right and part of what I'm doing right
now is looking at how the pandemic has
except is going to accelerate a lot of
the things that we've seen so
self-driving cars fully autonomous
cities by odomes people living on pods
[ __ ] robots I mean as much as we're
kidding around about all this it is kind
of true ahead okay that's why I had it I
would say it was blowing things up he
was blowing things up he knew he knew
we're not honest he called it an ADC
call I had a guy talking about how we're
gonna have people will use drones and
print plastic 3d guns let them just kill
people you know thoughts just have
everything they need crazy and they'll
fly a drone the next mass shooting is
gonna be from a drone buy some [ __ ]
how about there's a mass shooting at
Haneda and knows gonna make any new
16:25 get to Sara Lee anyone know fries
driving around right hey rap have you
been what in the part three and fours on
Sunday night have you been watching the
last dance thirty four thirty Oh Brian
Hickey Jim it's gonna say it's so
[ __ ] good you're not a sports guy
okay but you should
because you you like you can appreciate
you can appreciate uh somebody who's a
[ __ ] animal like you know what it
that somebody who pursuit of greatness
you see the speed job movie yeah like a
little bit my favorite well what is it
twenty thirty will go to a friend last
dance it's the Bulls just gonna see now
you got to see that I got I love that
because I'm I don't do this when you say
that but those have this Michael Jordan
hey rap I I think what's good to at this
thirty four thirty kids especially the
younger generation they don't realize
how good Jordan was when you see and
when he went for sixty three against the
Celtics and look at that Celtics team
they lost but he was still them you look
at that like holy [ __ ] dude they want to
say LeBron LeBron uh I get that argument
but you don't realize how special Jordan
was to go back and watch these tapes and
the [ __ ] mental
his mental was just it's like it's like
if he was he was Kobe know like Steve
Jobs or like some CEO of a company
Michael Jordan like he just was on some
other [ __ ] II never he never needed to
learn that tenacity and was he probably
a [ __ ] to play with he was an
[ __ ] but still was so his [ __ ]
Steve Jobs
so let's Kobe apparently yeah he's a
beast and and and if Bryan had the
chance Bryan if you had the opportunity
suck off Michael Jordan or Tom Brady I
know you're leaning forward he watch him
lean into this like that's a [ __ ] up
question man like well like I don't I
don't feel like I would in real life be
placed in that know if you had to go if
I had to know I'm not saying that chance
to if they're copper out yeah I've
already begun doing nothing the two
goats but I'm I'm a straight man no
favor I know but it's late in the night
you have a few drinks
I mean if Michael Jordan just sitting
there there's my god yeah Tom Brady's
like I'm the greatest you gotta go
Jordan you're gonna suck some black [ __ ]
I'm sucking Michael Jordan's got okay
hopefully because he's actually better
that's an easy question in every way now
so you do the same thing brandy I mean
if I have to yeah if there's a gun to my
head well you know and I don't think you
would need a gun to your head steady
pressure on the back of my head maybe
the steady pressure do you have to worry
about sucking dick around would be
Dennis Rodman and he's on the episode
three and four it's mainly Dennis Robb
and you know that did you see the other
ones no wait I saw one and two you've
seen all of them no no no I didn't see
him but oh no I was listening I think on
get out they were talking about how he
goes I have a whole stack Greenberg goes
I'm whole script here to tell you guys
watch the the last dance episode three
and four he goes all I gotta say is it's
their focus on Dennis Rodman
that should get everybody's attention
yeah I can't [ __ ] wait when you see
my back I pull myself up like a champ
thirty times while talking to you why
wouldn't I give that to you as it's a
gif it's a gift it's a gift